BRENDAN KENNY: And
it's brought you
mostly by Mike Bostock.
And here we can see a
bunch of examples.
So the great thing about the
d3 is there's just tons and
tons of examples, all
with code to let you
know how to do them.
And a big part of the d3 has
been geoapplications--
so using geographical data and
doing visualizations with this
geographical data.
So for the most part, it seems
like d4 lives separately from
something like a Maps
application.
But really all it does is, takes
data and binds it to
some way of displaying
that data.
That's kind of the underlying
thesis of d3--
Data Driven Documents is
what the d3 stands for.
And so we can take advantage
of that, to use kind of d3
skill sets and the tools d3
brings, and put it on top of a
map so that you can put
things in place.
So we're going to start with a
really simple example, just to
show how this kind of binding
to the Maps API works.
So here's a cool example
that's been highlighted
recently by Mike.
And it has to do with, well,
scale-dependent sampling as it
says on screen--
using the kind of scale of the
thing that you're displaying
and the amount of precision that
you need to show at that
scale to re-sample a line so
that you get a smooth curve.
And you can see here that we
have these control points
multiply as you zoom
in so you get a
really nice smooth curve.
But as you zoom out it starts
eliminating these control
points so that you don't draw
too many of these line
segments, filling pixels that
you would never see in the
first place.
And so we're going to use
that and bring it
over to this example.
So here all I've done is taken
that same exact thing.
I've removed the animation just
so it's slightly less
distracting.
And whereas this is some triggy
projection, this is
just a really simple Mercator
projection.
And I've taken a line.
And all I'm doing is saying,
show me a line that kind of
undulates around the equator.
And if you want to see what that
looks like, it just looks
like this right here.
I'm just defining a line string
kind of in this GeoJSON
like format.
And I'm keeping it right
on, around the equator.
So here's 20 degrees north past
the equator, 20 degrees
south and back again.
And then it just rotates
around the earth.
And so the key thing here is,
actually we only have five
points-- really four.
It begins and ends at
the same point.
But d3 knows that you want
to draw a great circle.
And so it actually fills then
and smooths that curve for us.
So that's great.
It's now in a different
projection, and that's a great
thing about d3 is that you can
throw any projection in the
world at it.
But really we want to bring
this into Google Maps.
So how do we do this?
So the way that d3
renders paths--
well, the way that most examples
of d3 render paths
either falls down to
SVG or Canvas.
So these are the two kind of
newer browser technologies,
"newer" browser technologies,
that let us draw things
dynamically.
So each brings its
own benefits.
So SVG lives in the DOM, you
can add mouse events to it.
You can select things after the
fact and do logic on that
sort of thing.
Whereas Canvas, it
gets rasterized,
puts it into display.
But then you get really fast
display if you have maybe
thousands or millions
of elements.
That's what lets you do WebGL,
you can rasterize to an image
and put it on screen, even if
it's a huge amount of elements
that you could never
put in the DOM.
So each has its trade-offs.
But really, it's actually
abstracted.
There's actually an interface
that d3 uses to write to these
different graphics contexts.
And there's different methods
that it uses that lets you
bind SVG or the Canvas to the
thing you want to display, in
this case a path.
You want to draw
this red path.
So we're going to use the
Canvas kind of method of
binding these things, because
it's a little bit easier.
So if you dig into that to
d3 docs, you can go to
d3.geo.path here.
And if you look, we can
see path.context.
So this is actually used in that
code that we were looking
at, where we create
a path from that
line around the equator.
And then when that path is being
created, actually, we
have a context that we pass
it to draw to, sort of.
But if you just look at the code
afterwards, you'll see
what I mean.
But you pass through
the context and it
binds to that context.
But if you look at these docs,
it doesn't actually have to be
a Canvas context.
All it has to do is fulfill
a certain interface.
And here are the following
methods that you have to
fulfill if you're implementing
that interface.
So you beginPath, moveTo,
lineTo, arc, and closePath.
And so if you've ever used HTML5
Canvas those should look
very familiar.
Those are the basic
drawing tools.
And it allows you to construct
paths and then, once you have
that path kind of in your
context state, you can either
stroke it or fill it.
But there's no reason, again,
that this has to be in Canvas.
Again, it's just an interface.
And we can actually fulfill
that ourselves.
And if you look, there's
actually scattered throughout
examples-- you'll see places
where they cheat.
And they actually pass a context
in to buffer objects
into an array, for instance, and
then pass that array to a
different way of rendering.
So that's what we're
going to do.
We're going to cheat and we're
going to implement this
context in terms of the v3 Maps
API geometry methods.
So let's go back to the code.
And I've created this really
simple thing called the
PolyLineContext.
And it's about as dumb
as you can get.
And it relies on the fact that
in this case we know we have
just a line.
So we don't have to worry about
polygons, for instance,
that might have breaks with
different polyline rings that
we then need to fill.
Or we don't have to
worry about arcs.
We know that it's never actually
going to call arcs.
Because we'd be in trouble if
it tried to call an arc.
So we've implemented these four
methods on this polyline
context, or five methods.
And most of them do nothing.
So beginPath, we don't
really care.
It doesn't do anything.
In that case you could've made
it so it creates a new
polyline, for instance.
The same thing with
arc and closePath.
These are just empty functions,
and in fact they're
never actually called
by the path code.
And the important ones are
moveTo and lineTo.
And I've made a really
simple method here.
It's actually the same for both,
where if a current path
is selected--
sorry, a polyline on the map is
selected, then I create a
LatLng object and push that on
to the polyline path array.
And so if we go to the
map code, we have two
things going on here.
We have-- first we initialize
a map, just like always.
And on that map we
make a polyline.
And then we init d3 to do
the same thing as in
the previous example.
But now instead of context from
a Canvas, now we're doing
a polyline context, that context
we just made up.
And when we create our path
object, that's with our
equi-rectangular projection so
that we can do-- just like an
identity projection.
We pass that to the context.
So now, we're finally at
the point when we can
actually draw this.
And so to draw it we've changed
our style methods that
set properties on Canvas context
to setting those
options on the polylines.
So we have a red and a
stroke weight of two.
And then we set our current
polyline, that's part of the
polyline context
that we wrote.
And finally, we just pass it
to this path method that we
created up here.
And that projects those points
and then passes it to the
context through those
five functions, or
really two in this case.
And just calls point, point,
point, point, point.
And so finally we can take a
look at what that looks like.
And if we refresh we can see
that we have this line.
In fact, let's make it a little
thicker, just a little
bit more obvious.
You can see this path
that we've created.
And so we're actually using
the d3, all its different
machinery, and then driving
these points on the map.
So this could be anything.
So in this case I created a
simple GeoJSON in code.
But you can bring
that GeoJSON in.
You can use topojson, which is
natively supported by d3.
You can use any sort of thing
and pass it in to draw these
draw commands.
And then, just like we drew
these polylines, we can also
draw polygons, that
sort of thing.
You just have to be careful
with your context.
And so just as a last, really
simple example, we can see as
we zoom in we get these hard
corners here where you see a
definite angle.
So we're not adaptively
re-sampling.
And so we can actually do a
couple of things there.
We can tell that d3 that
the scale has changed.
Or we can totally cheat and go
to the console here and just
set the precision of the
projection manually.
So here we've moved to a
much smoother polyline.
And we can even do that-- so on
Zoom, for instance, we can
change the precision of
the polyline if we
wanted to do that.
And it goes the other
way, too.
We can set so it's just like
this very angular thing.
And so, as you can see, it's
the full pipeline.
It's really easy to bind.
And so that's something to keep
in mind in the future
when you're looking at
kind of, I want d3.
But I also want to put on a map
if it actually needs to be
in context.
And so there's no reason why
these can't live together. d3
is designed exactly for this
kind of adaptability.
So try it out.
Check out the code, where it's
going to be in a simple gist
linked on the video.
And let me know what
you think.
And if anything interesting
comes up we can covered in
future Maps Shortcuts.
Thanks.